[Music]
these planking with over 200 is amazing
this is us start Justin Hartley showing
us what he does on his quote Daniel I
gotta badass right I got a woman who
knows her plank that's for sure by the
way Justin loci Mathison over here
suggested short off a lot more than that
in a bad mom's Christmas and we are
taking you exclusively behind the scenes
first of all doing a comedy is it's
wonderful you're laughing all day long
and to be part of that cast of those
powerhouse women it's the same this sexy
Santa brings a lot of cheer to these
moms stressed over the holidays the 40
year old was the perfect casting choice
[Music]
it was like um hi how are you good to
meet you Catherine and legs go up and
here we go let's do this
Catherine Mila and Kristen need to blow
off some steam while trying to make
Christmas perfect for their families
it's just what we as women to have to
deal with during the six days leading up
to Christmas the help of getting
Christmas perfect energy but they're
stressed and they swear and they want to
have wine sometimes and
okay every mom needs a little bit of
time off
who cares if you burn a cookie and if
things weren't amped up enough the moms
mom showed up trying to top them off
please
you're working we're stayed home mom
we're struggling mom or the mom that has
it all I think that it allows you to go
oh my god I'm not alone these people get
me look at me like I'm not even a mom
and I feel like y'all get me okay
[Music]